[Music]
government officials are not allowed to
sell access to the United States
government even sitting vice presidents
like Joe Biden are not allowed to do
that it's a crime it is also a crime for
anyone in the United States to commit
fraud to defraud their business partners
now in the portion of interview that you
just saw Tony bobolinski presented
evidence which We examined that Hunter
Biden did this he committed fraud
against Tony boblinski and his other
business partners the Biden family did
that now bobolinski gave that evidence
to the FBI
what happened next we asked Tony
bobolinski
now since you are at the very center of
the story since you were the CEO of
steinhawk Holdings I wish I wasn't right
I I know I know that's right and I want
to ask about that in a minute because
it's a sad story
but since you are as a factual matter at
the very center of this story
tell us about your personal interactions
with the FBI
so uh you know well uh well documented I
was I went to the second debate in
Nashville between uh president Trump and
Joe Biden my son has not made money in
terms of this thing about uh what are
you talking about China I have not had
the only guy made money from China is
this guy he's the only one nobody else
has made money from China that night I
flew to DC and the next morning there
was a big debate do I voluntarily walk
into the FBI or do I go sit down with
Senator Johnson and Senator Grassley my
my lawyers decided it was better that I
voluntarily go in uh to sit and and
provide these facts and so in the
morning of October 23rd the morning
after the debate
um I spent five plus hours sitting in a
room uh with at one point I think as
much as six federal agents walking
through all the facts of my knowledge of
the Biden family
um how I got involved in this you know
the the trips around the world you know
CFC chairman you and stuff like that at
the end of that meeting and remember I
voluntarily went there so they were
happy to take any information I provided
to them I wish I had pictures of the
faces of the two main agents that were
interviewing me because I would say
something and you could just see the
shock in their face and they would say
hey let's take a minute they'd get up
and walk out of the room and the Agents
would sort of convene and then come back
and restart the interview because these
facts are just for the sake of our
country for National Security at that
point he was a candidate Joe Biden now
he's the sitting president of the United
States the most powerful person in the
Free World and um daunting so at the end
of that five plus hour interview the
head of station uh told my lawyers
listen an individual named Tim Tebow is
going to run points on all of this we're
definitely going to have Tony come back
in for a follow-up interview could be as
early as next week some of the people
that were in the room weren't well
versed on all these facts we may want to
have people come in from Baltimore or
Delaware and you know I was ready to sit
down with anybody that needed me to or
travel wherever I wanted to and um and
so the head of station gave my lawyers
Tim Tebow's cell phone number Tim was
not there that day I think he was out of
Washington DC but my lawyers had an hour
hour and a half call with him that
Friday night October 23rd and subsequent
calls through the weekend and the
following week when I was then coming on
your show to provide the facts of the
American people
and
um they were supposed to be working a
follow-up interview and Tim Tebow in his
last discussion with my legal counsel
was listen we know Tony's cooperating we
appreciate all the information he's
provided uh we will follow up with you
we're definitely going to have him come
in uh for a follow-up interview or spend
some more time on this and um I haven't
heard from him since
at all no
nor have my lawyers no communication
whatsoever no since before the 2020
election correct
it's shocking
uh shocking yeah that would be one
adjective yeah tell us about Tim Tebow
um I didn't interact with him my lawyers
did and had extensive discussions
obviously all this information very
sensitive
um and how it was being handled
um the images off my cell phones uh
detailed you know WeChat discussions
with the Chinese you know wires change
just the amount of information here is
staggering and the FBI took possession
of that information they did
I don't know where it went so
um I do know you know to your point
earlier of one of the reasons why I'm
sitting here you know during the summer
there's been all this discussion now
about whistleblowers coming forward
coming forward to Senator Grassley
Senator Johnson uh Congressman Jordan
Congress Comer I mean it sounds like
they're coming out you know out of the
woodwork and I think it will continue to
accelerate and apparently a variety of
these whistleblowers uh claim that Tim
Tebow was suppressing facts so imagine
I'm actually in Europe traveling and I'm
starting to see these you know I call my
lawyers monthly why haven't I been
called in front of a grand jury well
this makes no sense to me they said they
were going to follow up within a you
know a week and do follow-up interviews
and my lawyers were just you know let
the process work through I had respect
for office our country I was trying to
respect the Department of Justice sure
through but then when you hear the
person that you're told was assigned to
run point on thousands of documents and
uh text messages and calendar and you
know travel arrangements and all that
that that individual just walked out of
the you know the FBI uh headquarters in
DC he's got to start asking questions so
and the allegation is that he's a
partisan actor acting on behalf of
effectively the Democratic party that's
the allegation about it yeah apparently
multiple whistleblowers have come
forward and claimed that correct
would you speak to the FBI again I'd be
happy to at any time at any time not
only not just the FBI uh the U.S
attorney uh I mean these facts are
extensive well documented easily
verified metadata multiple sources
saying the same thing zero chance that
this has anything to do with Russia or
disinformation so we've heard repeatedly
accounts that there's is or was a grand
Journey jury impaneled in Delaware
what do you know about that
um I know one thing I haven't been
called in front of them and uh which is
uh surprising
disappointing I don't know you were the
business partner family some people say
you know aren't you happy that you
didn't have to go through and sit in
front of people for 20 hours getting
asked a thousand questions and I say uh
no our country deserves the facts they
need to know about the facts and when
you have a media and
um you know some of the biggest tech
companies Facebook Twitter publicly
acknowledging that they did suppress the
story Jack Dorsey at Twitter publicly
acknowledging it was a mistake we made a
total mistake with the New York Post we
corrected that within 24 hours it was
not it was not to do with the content it
was to do with the Hacked materials
policy we changed that based on
um they're not wanting to delete that I
completely agree with I see it but it is
it is something we learn it wasn't a
do-over we didn't get to go back and fix
that history was altered uh this was
this is
history altering facts debate with
anybody put me in a room with anybody
that claims anything I've said any
document I've I've produced is altered
or fabricated I'd love that challenge
FBI director Chris Ray dispatched his
agents on the largest Manhunt in
American history to apprehend an
incarcerate
hundreds of middle-aged people with no
criminal records for trespassing in the
United States Congress when the Capitol
Police lifted the guards and let them in
that's what they've been spending their
time doing but not one FBI agent could
call Tony bobolinski back who presented
them hard documentary evidence of
felonies the Biden family committed how
is that not corruption and who's behind
it subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight